- Il suffit de les apercevoir
quelques instants pour
comprendre qu'ils vont
rapidement atteindre le statut
de vedettes : trois chatons
lynx, deux femelles et un mâle,
qui explorent leur tout nouvel
habitat, le Biodôme de Montréal.
- Des be lynx,
vraiment très beaux à voir,
toute une merveille de pouvoir
les voir aujourd,hui.
- Est-ce que vous avez vu
les petits chats?
- Est-ce qu'ils sont beau?
- Oui
- Les chatons sont nés
le 1er mai dernier.
Leur croissance, comme celle
de tous les félins, est rapide.
Après deux mois d'allaitement,
ils étaient déjà solides
sur leurs pattes.
Puis, il y a dix jours, ils ont
commencé à découvrir le monde
extérieur, celui du Biodôme et
de ses très nombreux visiteurs.
STÉPHANIE LAGACÉ, techn., soins
animaliers, Biodôme de Montréal
- Souvent, on a l'impression,
quand ils grandissa a
l'air d'un chat de maison,
mais assez rapidement,
on voit les attribut qui fait
que ça se différencie.
s grosses pattes pour
marcher dans la neige, les
petits poils sur les oreilles
qui caractérisent cette espèce-
là, des choses comme ça, etvrai,
l'instinct sauvage.
- Comme l'habitat des lynx est
très réduit, l'équipe du Biodôme
a développé des outils pour
encourager le développement
des chatons. Odeur, goût,
obstacles physiques,
l'exercice est quotidien.
- On va vraiment les pousser sur
des sens qu'ils utiliseraient
normalement pour les forcer
à travailler, t'sais, il y a pas
de bol. Ta nourriture, il fa
que tu travailles pour l'avoir.
Puis, même si ça te prend toute
la journée, ça te prend toute
la journée. Mais, il y a rien
de gratu
- D'ici un an, les chatons
auront atteints leur taille
d'adultes, soit entre vingt
et trente kilos. Il faudraalorss
une institution qui partage
la même vision que le Biodôme :
Présenter des animaux sauvage
au grand public, mais également,
au besoin, assurer leur survie
à long terme.
GHEYLEN DAGHFOUS, conservateur
Biodôme de Montréal
- Les lynx qui son
soins humains peuvent servir de
population d'assurance advenant
qu'il se passe quelque chose
en milieu naturel ou de support
lation en milieu
naturel si on avait besoin
de réintroduire des idividus
en nature.
- Et, pour ceux qui se demandent
peut-être quel sont les noms
des trois petites vedettes
du Biodôme, la réponse est
simple.
- Ici, on veut vraiment
l'expéri en forêt.
Donc, en forêt, les animaux ont
pas de nom, on suit ce même
principe-là au Bi